or en réalité pour moi faire pour ma
part ça va être très court parce que eh
bien les trois personnes différentes je
partageais et c'est une agréable
surprise en réalité leurs propos comme
quoi même provenant de disciplines
variées on peut s'entendre et je trouve
que c'est très intéressant et c'est
c'est particulièrement prometteur la
seule chose que j'aurais aimé ajouter à
la prise de produits la prise de parole
première c'est qu'il a été évoquée la
question d'un violent filmées et
j'aimerais juste apporter une petite
précision pénalement le film est une
infraction sexuelle quelle qu'elle soit
et en particulier une agression sexuelle
c'est prohibé ça s'appelle de happy
slapping le fait de filmer et de
rediffuser je ne suis pas convaincu que
pénalement on parlerait pornographie je
pense qu'on serait quand même sous
l'application de ce délit très
spécifiques
je crois que c'est totalement éloigné le
fait de filmer un viol ou une agression
sexuelle un réel qui se passe qui s'est
produit 2 parce qu'elle a été rappelé
par par monsieur sony perd c'est quand
ils évoquèrent le fait de leur contexte
qui est à la fois qu'il l'a très bien
expliqué cette question la stimulation
qui permet de faire le distinguo de
faits qui se sont produits film est une
infraction c'est prohibé surtout si bien
évidemment c'est une infraction sexuelle
est différent du fait de simuler une
mise en scène fort ces contraintes en
tout cas pénalement parce que je n'ai
pas souvent nous discipline que je ne
maîtrise pas en termes d'effets pour le
spectateur
[Musique]